hello everyone and welcome to the actual
second leg of the magnus carlsen chest
or Dylan Doris a be rapid tournament
which follows the at the Magnus
Invitational and it's a very nice game
between Magnus Carlsen and LaVon Ireland
in round one Magnus defeated Alex and
Alicia and 11 defeated Alireza Fallujah
so here Magnus gets his second white in
a row
as sometimes you know you do get two
whites in row but sometimes you get two
blacks in row so it doesn't really
matter in the end it should all even out
but here it's a it's a really really
interesting game as we have a case of
the Petrov defense where Magnus offers a
sacrifice overnight now the sacrifice is
not accepted but it's still a really
really awesome game so without further
ado let's check it out it's a 12 player
tournament after the preliminaries round
after the preliminaries they go into the
knockout phase so out of those 12 eight
players will go into the knockout phase
of the tournament and we're gonna take
it from there and also check out some
standings so II four by Magnus and we
have E 5 by 11 we have Knight f3 Knight
to f6 so going for the Petrov defense
and Knight captures on e5 we have these
six Knight goes back in the night
captors on e4 and now Knight to c3 the
names of each attack
we have Knight captures and c3 by 11 D
captures on c3 which nicely opens up
your both of your bishops and now Bishop
to e7 Levin prepares the castle we have
Bishop to e3 and now castles a magnus
agos Queen to d2 he wants the Castle
queenside and Knight to d7 now preparing
to ship the other night over to f6
we have queenside castle by Magnus and
now c6
i preparing to grab more space in the
center with d5 also now that the bishop
is only 7 that d6 pawn is nicely
protected and here there are a lot of
moves possible the most often played is
working to b1 as you are expecting the
Queen to land on a5 going after that a
to pawn and there are actually quite a
lot of games that to go into this Queen
a 5 c4 then we have a queen trade and so
on but here we have h4 by Magnus and
okay 11 and grabs more space in the
center we have d5 and now Bishop to b3
so a pretty
much completing the development and now
well you could go Quinta a five here and
they try to sort of get a get the same
idea going with rook to e8 by 11 and now
rook DT 1 not rook HD 1 as you don't
want your rook on the H file and here
there is one game in the database where
Bishop to c5 was played but here we have
Knight to f6 and it is as I've moved 12
that we have a completely new game so
Magnus immediately went Knight to g5
which which kind of tries to provoke h6
to get some weakening in front of the
King but lemon first goes c5 he wants to
play c4 and get rid of this light square
bishop you don't want this bishop at
night eyeing the h7 pawn and now c-4 by
Magnus so of course not allowing black
to push c4 and here we have h6 finally
going after that night and here Magnus
did spend some time I think it was
around almost 5 minutes like four and a
half minutes and in the end he played
CCAP force on d5 so not not going back
with the night because there is actually
quite a lot to calculate for example now
usually you know that it's it's pretty
bad to capture the mind but here it's
not so simple now because after the
knight is captured of course you get a H
character Sanji 5 you no longer have D
squares available for the night so you
could go back 97 but then you get to b6
and it's it's a terrible position for
black if you captured in Bishop h7 check
picks up at the dark square bishop and
if you go something like a bishop to f8
and then you go into Bishop h7 check
King to a trade and now Bishop to g6
check King to g8 and now Queen d3 with
some really nasty ideas for example if
the bishop is captured Queen b5 check
forces checkmate as the rook still
covers the H file and if you don't
capture the bishop if you play something
else let's say Bishop captures and e6
you try and give away some material this
way then you run into the very
unpleasant rook the h8 check so nothing
nothing for blacks to do here at King
captures Bishop captures on f7 now the
bishop covers or both of these squares
and rook to h1 is unstoppable so there
is nothing to do here
so Magnus at some point probably had
this over the board as
prepare for the Petrova during his World
Chess Championship match against Khurana
but it's probably been quite some time
since he looked at it so he he had to of
course remember if it was okay to leave
in the night stranded on g5 but xi
decided to ignore that and he played c4
Queen captures on b5 is the way to go
here
however lemon played c4 now it's
probably kind of a mixture of being
greedy and playing for a win I think it
was more playing for a wind and then
trying to be greedy here xi wants to get
this bishop away from this diagonal so
he can finally capture this Knight and
madness captures the pawn not much you
can do about that so H captures and G
5:11 grabs the night and now H captures
and g5 with Knight to e4 d4 square now
is available as the bishop no longer
guards it but now Queen to d1 the Queen
is also under attack so Magnus goes
Queen to d1 now preparing Queen h5
followed by Queen to h8 checkmate
so Bishop captures on g5 and now Queen
to h5 again threatening the same
checkmate and here 11 again goes for
Bishop captures and needs to recheck
Bishop to h6 would have been a much more
resilient idea it's not good for black
but it's it's not at all clear
immediately how to take advantage of it
for example after Bishop captures you go
back 96 you open up an attack to the
Queen and to the rook here after the
Queen moves yes you're threatening
checkmate but first rook captures anyone
with Czech rook characters now at least
you've got one of the rooks away from
the H file and now Queen to f8 defending
checkmate and now it's you know it's a
position of white of course it's much
better but you still have to find the
correct idea point is that this is the
the the idea you have to open up this
diagonal and now rook to e7 will be very
strong for example Bishop d7
look to the e7 and now Bishop to EA to
guarding f7 and now it's well it's just
a wonderful position for example there's
Queen h4
now if the bishop is captured you can
always capture the night and if rook to
b8 and then you just go
Bishop to f4 you guard the pawn and the
black pretty much has no moves you're up
to pawn
and well black is just completely
paralyzed but it would be it would be
much more resilient than Bishop captures
on e3 11 play Bishop captures in e3
would check
Magnus recaptured with the rook and now
there's still the threat of checkmate so
let me play it f5 he gave himself an
escape route for the King but now d6
check now opening up this diagonal as
well Bishop to e6 blocking but here 11
just played Queen to h7 check sorry
Magnus played Queen to h7 check and it
was in this position unmoved 22 that 11
aragon resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here it seems a
bit premature but he calculated
everything out and point is it's a it's
a really funny idea because after the
King moves
do you see a really cool way to win the
game for white it's not only cool it's
also the quickest way to win so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find it while I'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
supporting the Queen sacrifice and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
its Queen captures on f7 with check on
f5 with check and there's not much you
can do here if you go back with King to
g8 then just Bishop captures in e6 of
course that's just winning but if Bishop
captures then rook to h8 is checkmate as
the point in Bishop prevented the King
from reaching the seventh rank
so after this Queen captures an f5 check
obviously we cannot capture you could
block maybe Bishop f7 Queen captures and
f7 is again checkmate if you block with
the night it's not much better just
route captures in e6 and already yeah
you're there's not there's nothing wife
can do here rook the h8 is still coming
so here you could play rook captures on
e6 but then just to look at force on h8
with check King to f7 and now you don't
even have to go for the Queen just
Bishop captures here will be checkmate
and lastly but not leastly of course you
could block with the Queen but then just
Queen captures on e4 and again there's
not much to do if you if you go for the
bishop then rotate rate check just picks
up a lot of material if you go King to
g8 preventing that then just queen h7
check King to FA
and now Queen to h8 with Czech king f7
and Bishop captures and he says check
and white wins a lot of material wrote
characters Queen captures here and after
let's say captures captures white is up
a whole rook and the black does not have
any any counter play or or tricks so
Levin calculated all this out and after
Queen tej something check he resigned
the game and second victory for Magnus
car calls an indole indoors a be rapid
tournament we'll see how it goes
two more games today and then we're
gonna check out some other games and
also check out the standings so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank lars Jacob Scott
Gore theme Patrick character Thomas
Connors and Joseph Bessette for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the Lynn
Doris Abby rabbit tournament and
whatever else what happens in the chess
world so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day